não consegue se organizar grossa uma PG
que eu fico muito feliz de poder estar
aqui jogando com vocês que aconteceria
assim então sabendo que você acredita
que a gente comece a conversa eu
gostaria de pedir do vocês se levanta
E aí conforme eu vou dizendo algumas
frases que que você tenha passado pela
experiência por favor seguinte aqueles
que não passado é referência por favor
se escreve Vocês já tiveram professora
sua professores negros na educação
infantil 1
e se você já tiveram um sua atendidos
por médicos ou médicas telha 1
E aí
e quando você tiveram a oportunidade de
livros de literatura infantil que os
protagonistas o açúcar camisetas você
clica nele e
se você espera alguma novidade brigar
com bonecas e bonecos deles é
nós estamos bem Eu gostaria que vocês
olhassem alegando um
bom então essa Vocês não tem mais podem
ser obrigado a experiência que eu fiz
como vocês tão fofo da invisibilidade do
corpo negro em
E aí gente beleza por favor de
professores e isso aí trabalhar antena
do Forno raça identidades sociais Rafa
letramentos racial crítico e
extrativista é possível pesquisas que eu
ter efeito na alergia a
a Dilma parte autora estadunidense Negra
e agora vai conseguir e elitismo modelo
de sala de aula uma realidade viva ele
está vendo implora estava dentro por
isso só podemos pensar por exemplo o
relação nos momentos que estão
circulando em ambientes educacionais
vocês tentação infantil Ensino
Fundamental ensino médio Universidade
nós temos que tratá-las escolásticos
todos esses locais Será que nós passamos
de pensamos Quais são as identidades
sociais que são esses cartazes
eu posso fazer começar de volta seus
filhos e todos esses vírus não temos
livros de literatura antagonistas são
deles ou livro por vocês livros são
escritos por autores negros ou autorizei
podemos tentar também um porta e papo
que a gente não sabemos cidade e todos
nós estamos aqui tivemos a experiência
de uma forma ou de outra botar mental
seja um esse México e pertences
necessários desses livros práticos
e como é que irá representar o Brasil
hoje de acordo com o IBGE em cinquenta
por cento de precisar Ou seja no Brasil
somos marido e agora eu gostaria de
mostrar uma tabela para você ele Isabela
faz parte das vezes que eu fui vou aqui
não é perder o interesse pelo novo uma
precisar alimentação das pessoas
habilidades sociais dos estados e eu
separei dois do vocês podem perceber a
tabela se deve francas ou beneficio.de
ser iludido no teresiano da princesa e
eu e as minhas amigas resolvemos
o que se passa eu resultado de mais ou
menos olho corações universidades que
não sou eu mas também as minhas
orientadas analisar a
é separar 1/3 Cegonhas profissionais e
ele passada e atividades família e
atividades de lazer
e eu vou vocês podem fazer atividades
missionárias e atividades serão
realizadas e precioso por homens brancos
e mulheres brancas pelos familiares mais
nova mas não são 80 não consegue
materiais as pessoas em Barras se todos
nesse contexto brasileiro 18 aconselho a
gente resolveu felicidade As Margens EA
procurar sensação de velocidade para
entender as atividades serão usadas as
pessoas brancas é uma exercem atividades
intelectualizadas que estão mais
voltados a pessoas de subir então última
percebemos e a Marcele cientistas
Engenheiros é são as pessoas que não
pode ser desprezada de menor por vir
estão
é verdade isso aqui é o grupo familiar
que acaba sendo 61 por cento para
pessoas sendo para pessoas dele cuidar a
questão da visibilidade de outro e
aparece mais a pessoa França sendo
representada por ele família isso manda
mensagem para as crianças adolescentes
se reproduz Quebrou as pessoas a igreja
pertence onde há maior possibilidade
para não cidade de lado dele antes que
organizaram se deve esses dois por cento
das atividades nas diretrizes das
palavras e homem seduzir mulheres negras
nos processos aí todas as
a atividade de fazer celestes as
atividades coisa viagens diárias para
fora do Brasil atividades o relação
esportes dos esportes que tem mais é
poder econômico são exercício visual e
atividades de lazer com menor poder o
nome dele fazia exatos são exercícios
pessoas ler então a gente fala de
identidades sociais de caça nós estamos
falando somente das pessoas regra escuta
sol são os na semana sejamos nós né Aí
você entendeu eu não sou da Di Da Di
racial materializar e quais os impactos
e estudar tanto para crianças
adolescentes e adultos e quando Nós
pensamos nele para ela ir aí
e as pessoas que estão sempre gostaria
de fazer parte do poder poder que são
amizade sociais e esse problema
há 6 meses
e eu não sei se vocês olharem as imagens
mas eu disse idade tem um preocupando
Orlando dele eu queria da Sofia uma
viagem de pesquisa que nós fizemos ó
camarões e mais grupo de professores de
outras seis universidades
é um passado várias formas quando se
sabe eu sei que nove anos eu até ter 49
anos eu tive a oportunidade de ver uma
imagem como é uma doença complexa
representada por ele vai biologia Brasil
os seus livros todos os livros da que eu
tive a possibilidade de ter Então é
porque mais uma bosta da questão da
invisibilidade no o dedo na nossa
sociedade
o fundo eu sempre pouco de tentar a que
ações então eu posso fazer para achar
possibilidade dela pesquisas que eu cvou
e eu dela eu trabalho por motivos e
narrativa assim prata vergonha esse
pessoas se deram conta de tudo isso
existe uma pessoas trava em toda a minha
experiência de comer costela com outro
duas vezes mais uma delas e aparece tem
muita frequência e as pessoas sabemos
que quando elas eram pequenas elas nunca
tinham tido tiver uma boneca Negra ou
Colíder por favor brincar
a TV professora só professora trouxe
acidente antiga dizendo que alguém que
queira Você me ganhou muita boneca Pois
somente corretas loira de olhos azuis e
ela quando ela crescer eu acho que
certeza disso e agora nesse parecido com
aquela boneca porque aquela navegador
aparece e já volto outra narrativa diz o
seguinte essa começou ela foi fazer
parte de uma na festa de uma criança EA
criança ganhou um
E aí acho que consegui intensa os dois
aqui se aquela criança que teve aquela
de roupa naquele mais do que tentar
fazer dele é espírita da criança passou
por que ela não quiser fazer porque ele
é uma boneca mesmo se ela quisesse vir
aqui eu entrar várias bonecas 3D
é só que não sabe ainda a viver ou as
velocidades e a diversidade é bonita a
cidade é ótima Nós moramos em um país
que seja que você do modelo de boneca
são os risos Brasil São livros só
vencendo por cento como é que a gente
somente esteja por cento das Bonecas são
os Brasil postando aqui nós negros
precisar de acordo com o IBGE só se
lembra quanto por cento da população
brasileira então é para fazer com aquele
celular irrealidade do corpo dele é
é um pouco conexão das ações foi
inventando nossos nós podemos fazer
porque a gente teve papo país mais justo
e mais igualitário mas equitativo vai
vir não consigo limpar a boneca né Então
essa é uma questão que a criança a
questão da verso para outras pessoas que
podemos usar ela somos nós aqui estamos
nessa sala ou meus sobrinhos filhos
verbos uma criança aqui está em contato
no Zap muitos de nós temos contato com
os dentes Já que a gente como fazer
esses vasos apr
o materiais que esses materiais senhor
traz diversidade que a gente conseguir
as pessoas representada de forma mais
irritativa e a gente fica ativa que as
pessoas negras e respondendo desse
material de forma que elas sejam
protagonistas e tentando também para
depois de incrível térmicas Vargas no
sentido de que ela vai gostar comprar
e solicitar sugerir para que as pessoas
segundo a posição dentro ao foi só fazer
que os filhos tenham o adversidade
[Música]
o acreditamos que é nós termos e da
ansiedade brasileiros Vamos parar com a
novela Brasil e gostamos muito do Brasil
né então pode estar feliz e não
invisíveis para a população toda forma
saber como se relacionar com todas as
pessoas aposentadas e e depois eu posso
sempre de mensagem eu trouxe momento que
eu falei ele discípulos as físicas dos
lobos e eu trabalho muito no entanto
precisa ser amento racial a crítica não
isso tudo que eu acabei de fazer ele
falar
Oi tá entender sobre a questão de falar
sobre as experiências de faça racismo na
nossa sociedade velocidade como é que as
pessoas podemos pensar capacidade de
absorção mais igualitário Humanidade
para fazer as coisas reais o novo
banheiros sociais nós vamos aqui
obesidade através dos livros que nós
temos o progresso a morte nossas
educamos nossos filhos e a nossa
Além disso as pesquisas eu trabalhava no
momento que você amor nessa pesquisa
centramento fazer alguma você traz e as
possibilidades de diversões restantes
puxa eu não tinha pensado nessa Aquele
Mano que eu trouxe para você que se
vocês já tinha visto docente daticos ou
tratadas com sua mãe porque você não vai
se vocês talvez significava compactados
embaçadas como eu porque é
G1
oi fala
o meu ajudar posso te dar mais um são
igualitárias coisa que está ativa mais
humana mais inclusiva muito branco um
E aí